that's what we're doing in Ukraine plus
a lot of other things and this is about
so we can sell liquefied natural gas
among other things to Europe Russia
provided 40 percent of the of the energy
to Europe before the Ukraine war and now
the United States wants part of that and
that's what this is all about that uh so
we can sell more and we are we're right
now selling more liquefied natural gas
to Europe and we also that's why we blew
up the Nordstrom pipeline which nobody
will cover and we blew we blew it up at
and they're bragging about what a great
opportunity this is of course we did
that and why Germany will go along with
this you know Merkel wouldn't go along
with that she pushed on and she built
the nordstream pipelines but now whoever
their their political class are just
puppets and that's what Putin keeps
saying why is Europe going along with
the imperialism of the United States and
NATO which is exactly what this is so
people don't know that's what this is
they think that all of a sudden Putin
woke up one night and decided to one
morning he decided to invade Ukraine and
be a jerk and that's not what's
happening